[Music]
[Applause]
let's get to Rich Eisen popular host of
NFL Network and the Rich Eisen show
available on Roku rich on the call
Dolphins Chiefs from Germany that'll be
Sunday at 9:30 a.m. eastern Dan rovski
and Jason mccordi will be part of the
broadcast and Rich joins us now let me
hit you with the first question do the
Steelers know what they have in Kenny
picket um I think what they have in
Kenny picket yeah they they they have a
kid who's still you know um learning uh
growing and has a knack in the fourth
quarter that if he's close he's going to
get it done like uh it's kind of like
pick at time in the fourth quarter so
keep it close they've got a great
defense they don't take nearly as many
risks as maybe they should with such a
great defense they play close to the
vest and in terms of what they have with
Kenny picket is is just a guy who's
still learning I mean I had Jared gof on
my show the other day Dan and I said
you're the perfect guy to ask how long
do you think it takes for a quarterback
to be evaluated I mean when he went to
Detroit we all know everybody thought he
was basically being
excommunicated there and and Detroit if
they were ever going to get good would
probably have to go with somebody else
at least that was the General sense of
things and look at him now he said three
years uh I just don't think that may be
realistic uh in this day and age but so
I think that's what they think they have
in picket yeah it feels like they give
you two years that that see it used to
be three years and then these rookies in
their third year would get to play you
know they held him out for you know at
least one year it was rare when you
didn't didn't start but yeah I'm I'm I'm
not sure what they have but that offense
has been bad I get you know piet's
thrown for 275 or more once in his
career he's thrown for multiple tou
sounds once in his career is it him is
it the system they do have some
offensive weapons there is it the
offensive
coordinator uh I think you ask a Steeler
fan they give you the answer who it is
you know they blame Canada like it's you
know South Park um you know or Team
America so bottom line is uh does it
matter I guess at this point in time I
guess it matters if you've going to end
up taking on either one of the teams
that I'm going to be seeing here in
Germany um you know you're going to end
up having to put up 21 maybe 28 to win a
football game and that seems to be a
challenge for him but right now despite
being outpointed uh or out uh out gained
right I think I saw that on sher's
Twitter account today that uh they're
the the only team in the history of the
NFL to be outgained as much as they've
been outgained through eight games to
have a winning record through those
eight yeah um and that that's a
testament to the defense and probably
Tomlin I would say all right give me the
storyline obviously a marquee match that
you have in Germany but what do you
think the one story line is the major
one is I think the major story line is
um this Dolphins uh offense against the
chief's defense because the chief's
defense has been the unit that has this
team at six and two which is remarkable
to say when there's Mahomes and Kelce on
the offensive side but it has been uh
spagnolo's defense that has carried the
day so far for the Chiefs and uh they're
known for playing man-to-man coverage
and we had our production meeting with
uh Tyreek hill yesterday and asked him
if he expects to see man coverage and he
smiled you know so um that's it right
there is how will this Chief's defense
cause Tua to hold the ball for the
proverbial extra second and if they do
play Man defense what happens when their
former teammate comes in you know we had
u a conversation as a production staff
with uh Travis Kelce yesterday and I
even said to him hey are you telling any
of these young kids on your defense
there's a ton of first and seconde
players on that defense in the back end
um who were not on the team when Tyreek
Hill was practicing against them like
hey you know like uh do you tell them
get ready because there's no simulating
this and he laughed and he's like you
know I I believe in my guys he gave the
I believe in my God speech but but he he
understands uh and I think uh everybody
who has a set of eyes understands what
happen when the cheetah gets out there
and um and he'll be there and it'll be
that's that's the the key I think to
this game but there's fast and then
there's fast guy F when when a fast guy
says Tyreek Hill is fast like that then
it resonates with me because there's a
lot of guys who are fast but there are
guys in the NFL who are really fast and
then they talk about Tyreek Hill fast
uhhuh like there's no simulating it in
practice there's no getting ready for it
there's just only experiencing when you
see it and we just came back from a our
meeting with Mike McDaniel of the
Dolphins um and he it was just awesome
chatting with him too Dan just to you
know get to get to hear him talk and his
philosophies and things of that nature
um and the thing that he talked about
about Tyreek Hill not just his speed but
was his his smartness his Brilliance in
understanding the game and how he worked
on fundamentals this off seon that he's
putting into play right now and I asked
him what he meant by that and he talked
about how he could position his feet
pre- snap and also read defenses in a
certain way with the understanding that
Tua is trying to on the Fly adjust to
the fastest player in the game and what
he's doing and how there's a
connectivity between Hill and Tua that
didn't exist last year and I think we're
seeing it and again that that's why I
choose this as the key to Sunday's game
rich NFL Network host he'll be on the
call with danovsky Jason mccordi that
will be Sunday at 9:30 a.m. eastern from
Germany he of course is the host of the
rich E and show on
Roku how did the Raiders fix the
Raiders oh gosh great question um I
think um what they did on Tuesday was a
start that it clearly wasn't working and
fixing it is to find I think the right
coach um general manager
combination um and the one that I
mentioned on my show if I was the owner
of any team in the AFC West my first
order of business when interviewing a
head coach is how are you going to stop
Patrick Mahomes how are you going to
keep the Chiefs from beating our brains
in and um the guy I think that might
have the answer to that is is Luan rumo
the defensive coordinator in Cincinnati
um he's the one who has actually done
this and done it effectively and um you
know he also is from Staten Island my
hometown and also a HomeTown of your
wife's you know and um and and maybe the
the guy whose dad sounded like he was
straight out of Brooklyn because he was
might actually uh want to go to that
sort of mentality that sort of system
and a guy who's like I know how to beat
momes or at least do my best let's
figure out a way offensively to find the
right quarterback because I think for
sure it ain't Jimmy G and and start from
there it's it's very easier said than
done um but that would be my plan if I'm
Mark Davis the tricky part with this
when we elevate a coordinator yes they
deserve it or they should get an
interview not everybody should be a head
coach Josh McDaniels is not a head coach
he's a coordinator and to be a head
coach you got to be a CEO and not
everybody can do it you can be a
coordinator and be Su it's like being a
pitching coach where you go man Leo
Mazon is an unbelievable pitching coach
but he's not you know Bobby Cox you're
you sometimes you know what you do well
and then we try to elevate you and go
hey Eric benemy deserves a chance okay
deserves a chance to be interviewed uh
but does is he going to be a head coach
I I I think we get into we hire people
sometimes who aren't ready to do it or
they're they're just not capable of
doing it even though they're really good
at being an offensive or defensive
coordinator and I guess that is the key
of of of what you would have to unearth
when you're doing these interviews again
just having met with McDaniel obviously
that's in my mind because it was just
about an hour and a half ago clearly he
understands the scheme in football he
was talking about how he was uh focused
on being a head coach in the NFL when he
he called it obsessed when he was four
years old is what he said he just
remembers that's all he's wanted to do
so clearly he has a Brilliance when it
comes to scheming the question was what
about the CEO portion of it as you
mentioned the the relating to players
portion of it and he at one point in
time when Jason mccordi who is part of
the team as you mentioned talked about a
scheme and how that's worked with Tua he
he stopped oh this is what it was how he
said that the chief's defense McDaniel
said um is excellent at so many other
things but they haven't seen everything
yet is what he said and he kind of
looked as McDaniel would comedically
around the room and I even said like
that sounds like a line that deserves
some theme music to it and mccordi
followed up assuming he meant scheme and
McDaniel stopped him and he said
actually what I was talking about that
the Chiefs haven't seen is an accurate
thrower of the football who throws
left-handed and he pushed back saying
it's the players that make this work and
it's him as a coach whose job it is to
make them great in their small window of
time and how he takes the responsibility
on himself for the players and we were
kind of sitting there even Stacy dalees
uh who is part of our broadcast team and
when I say even Stacy Dales I'm
referring to the fact that she a great
player at Oklahoma her jersey in the
rafters and is somebody who spent many
successful years in the WNBA she said
she never had a coach who sounded like
McDaniel when she was in the pros and
how she would have loved to have played
for someone like him now that question
is how do the Dolphins know that that's
that sort of guy that you're referring
to Dan right like he sounds like he's
got everything as a coordinator but what
about or a schemer what about that
portion and I I don't know if he showed
that to Stephen Ross in a meeting or
whatever but he's got it and the
question is how do you determine that
you're right it's a key question I'll
leave you with this Mike Florio and pro
football talk put this out there a
couple of days ago that yeah could he
see the Commanders trading for Bill bich
right and bich come in and you know the
new owner I think Ron Rivera will will
be replaced but if you brought in bich
Lombardi ended his career in Washington
DC but could you see Bill
bich wanting this
Challenge and that they would trade for
him well I'm seeing him here next week
we're sticking around in Germany for
Colts and um and Patriots um I'll I'll
try and glean that for you but I don't
imagine he'll wear it on his sleeve DP
but um but is he different though rich
in in those production meetings if
you're there with belich is he a little
more infusive where I have not had a
production meeting with him I I did
spend two days with him on the set of
the NFL 100 and NFL films and he was
just a dynamite awesome Storyteller and
completely different from the guy that
you see on the podium 100% but my my
only sense of it is if the
commander actions
of the trade deadline were in fact born
out
of um some form of Moneyball or some
sort of you know the process that that
Josh Harris has brought from
Philadelphia that's a general sense
amongst the you know information
community that there were some number
crunchers and let's get more draft picks
as opposed to hanging on to the players
that you hope your draft picks are going
to turn into in sweat and Chase Young
that if this is the philosophy that is
in fact ruling the Commander's
decision-making is that a spot that's
belich wants to go to I don't know you
know like there's a lot to come out and
the wash here um but um I I I I don't
know the answer to that question
obviously nobody does I I I find it hard
to believe um belich anywhere else quite
frankly but we'll see I I you know what
we were talking about this uh on the car
ride over to the Dolphins facility with
wanyama doing what he did last night and
like you know belich must be looking
around saying how do I get one of them
you know in my final years is coaching
like papovich guy can he get Caleb
Williams can I get Caleb Williams you
know like the same way that pop got
wembanyama so again we don't know how
this is going to play out for the
Patriots and what draft choice they're
going to hold and and anything like that
uh but I just if they're making
decisions based on well let's play money
let's get all these draft choices I
don't know if that's uh if that's Bill's
bag or not good to talk to you thank you
buddy to you DP thanks brother all right
Rich Eisen will be on the call NFL
Network it'll be 9:30 a.m. eastern and
that'll be the Dolphins and the Chiefs
Dan orlovski Jason mccordi and um Rich
Eisen show Monday through Friday from
noon to 3 Eastern on Roku Channel and
it's the 20th anniversary of NFL Network
this Saturday